et de la jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo l'eau
ou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
sb c'est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale vis
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 26 novembre
trois policiers suspendus et l'igpn
saisie en cause le tabassage d'un
producteur de musique samedi dernier à
paris dont la vidéo a été largement
diffusée aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux des événements qui amplifie la
controverse sur l'article 24 de la loi
sécurité globale le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin sera
d'ailleurs auditionné à l'assemblée
nationale ce lundi le service
après-vente de jean castex le premier
ministre a déroulé ce matin le menu
annoncé par emmanuel macron mardi soir
le premier ministre a annoncé que les
stations de ski seront ouvertes à noël
mais sans remontées mécaniques des
décisions jugées absurdes par
l'opposition restaurateurs cafetiers ou
encore gérants de discothèques ont
manifesté à marseille contre le maintien
cette fois de la fermeture de leur
établissement
près de 17 milliards de dollars c'est le
prix quand écouter le blocus de gaza par
israël l économie de l enclave
palestinienne entre 2007 et 2010 8 selon
un rapport de l'onu publié hier
l'organisation estime qu'il est urgent
d'y mettre fin à gaza aujourd'hui un des
taux de chômage de 2 chômage les plus
élevés au monde aux alentours de 50 2%
[Musique]
la vidéo a fait l'effet d'une bombe en
plein examen du projet de loi sécurité
un enregistrement diffusé par le site
d'information l'outsider qui montre un
homme noir agressée par trois policiers
dans le xviie arrondissement de paris
samedi dernier une scène violente qui
fait vivement réagir y compris le
ministre de l'intérieur jonathan mois
d'hab avec thomas bonnin voici les
images diffusées par le site
d'information l'outsider pendant de
longues minutes un homme michel et roué
de coups par trois policiers
la scène se déroule samedi dans le
studio parisien de ce producteur de
musique
le point de départ de l'intervention
policière serait une absence de masques
mais très vite l'opération de police
prend des allures de pugilat une grenade
lacrymogène va même être lancée à
l'intérieur des locaux l'homme frappé
par les policiers affirment aussi avoir
subi des insultes racistes à la suite de
cette intervention michel a été placé en
garde à vue pendant 48 heures mais grâce
à la présentation des images de
vidéosurveillance les poursuites à son
encontre ont finalement été abandonnées
et ce sont désormais les trois policiers
qui sont visés par une enquête ouverte
par l'igpn la police des polices
c'est d'ailleurs au siège de cette
institution qui ont été reçus michel et
son avocate ce jeudi ça a été tellement
tellement difficile à vivre
j'étais quand ils ont lancé lacrymogènes
j'étais au fond j'ai essayé d'appeler
mon avocat gc a plaidé
plein de gens et j'ai même - voisins qui
entendaient may cry qui m'appelle qui me
dis qu'est ce qui se passe je suis
agressée et j'appelle la police mais
c'est la police qui est derrière
enfin c'est du n'importe quoi
pas vous dire ce que j'attends mais
c'est vrai que j'aimerais si jamais au
moins ça peut servir à ça d'ailleurs
j'aimerais que ça ne recommence plus
bien sûr pour personne et caméras ou pas
caméra ça devrait pas arriver sont là
pour nous protéger dit lapointe de tout
ce sont qui font bien leur travail
nous allons déposer plainte compte tenu
des violences qui ont été commises il ya
également une violation de domicile
violences avec arme par personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
donc nous nous y allons nous avons
rendez vous cette affaire montre une
nouvelle fois l'intérêt de la vidéo pour
prouver les abus lors d'une intervention
policière en plein débat sur la loi
sécurité globale adoptée cette semaine
par l'assemblée nationale ces images
suscitent un écho considérable dans
l'opinion et parmi les élus
ils sont nombreux à s'être insurgé
contre le comportement de ces policiers
et certains d'entre eux appellent à
manifester de nouveau contre cette loi
controversée malgré l'interdiction des
autorités un rassemblement est prévu ce
samedi à paris
cette affaire ne faisant que renforcer
la volonté des manifestants
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
carbon de 16 avocats au barreau paris
bonsoir m merci d'être avec nous une
vidéo choc qui semble à peine croyable
quand on regarde les faits une première
réaction
bonsoir à la wii la première réaction
c'est que heureusement qu'il y avait des
caméras surveillance parce que sinon le
dit michel partait dans une procédure
mensongère mais qui aurait abouti
effectivement vous dit heureusement que
c'était filmé beaucoup à vue dans cette
affaire
l'occasion de rappeler en tout cas pour
les antilles article 24 de la loi de
sécurité à quel point il était
indispensable de filmer les policiers
c'est votre avis aussi aujourd'hui c'est
une illustration de l'année c'est
citer 2 contre et 7 3 qui a été je le
rappelle voté à l'assemblée nationale
déjà alors d'abord c'est l'illustration
d'une mauvaise pratique c'est celle de
produire ou au coeur de la république
des procès verbaux mensonges et
sciemment erronée falsifiant la vérité
et donc de commettre des faux en
écriture publique et ses faux en
écriture publique sont considérés par la
loi française comme des crimes donc ça
n'est pas anodin comme méthode la
deuxième conclusion en tirer c'est que
cette façon de procéder jette la
suspicion sinon l'opprobre sur la façon
dont sont rédigées les procès verbaux
d'interpellations avec cet après midi
des excuses de la part de certains
syndicalistes pas tout ce qui était
surprenante
par exemple le fait de dire qu'il ne
portait pas son masque mais le fait de
porter un masque est une contravention
donc une contravention n'autorise pas en
cas de flagrant délit à entrer chez les
gens de même que on a entendu quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est à dire qu' il
était défavorablement connu des services
de police mais en quoi servent autorise
une interpellation qui relève de bibi
qualité la plus complète
donc si vous voulez j'ai trouvé que
autant ce débat est intéressant autant
les arguments qui était avancé ce n'est
comme autant d'aveux concernant
l'article 24
c'est une illustration supplémentaire du
fait que de toute façon ce qui se passe
sur la voie publique doit pouvoir être
capté une image et qu' il n'y aurait
aucune raison pour que l'état puisse
surveiller l'ensemble de la population
avec des drones et que la population ne
puisse pas un film et la façon dont
interviennent les forces de l'ordre et
je crains que cette affaire ne
produisent un sentiment d'insécurité
chez beaucoup de gens qui se trouvent en
présence des gardiens de la paix ce qui
est extravagant effectivement
enquête a été ouverte contre les trois
policiers qui ont été suspendus on le
rappelle pour violences également il
faux en écriture que faut-il faire
justement vous parliez des pv des procès
verbaux qui sont rédigées l'homme est
tout d'abord accusée d'outragé rébellion
comment contrer justement si ce type de
fausses informations
je crois qu'il ya un travail d'abord qui
est fait par l'igpn sans peut s'en
réjouir mais si vous voulez le malaise
qui va naître un des succès c'est dur
c'est que il y a trois lampistes qui
vont payer et que les méthodes ne vont
pas changer et ça c'est la
responsabilité du politique c'est de
bien marquer son autorité et de ne pas
laisser les syndicats de police entier t
sur sa son autorité la difficulté c'est
que monsieur darmana à l'invitation des
syndicats ou is a voulu envoyer un
signal d'impunité aux forces de l'ordre
eh bien on voit chez ceux qui sont
tentés d'abuser de ce sentiment
d'impunité
ce que ça produit dans les faits pour
plus apple annonce que vous le dites on
nous dit ce sont des lampistes ils se
sont quand même acharné effectivement ça
semblait comme un règlement de compte
plusieurs coups une vingtaine je crois
est ce que dans ces cas là on entend
votre idée mais est ce que le politique
est vraiment responsable
oui je crois je vous remercie de
souligner est exonéré leurs
responsabilités moi ce que je suis c'est
droit à un procès équitable métier or il
y a deux procédures engagé une procédure
disciplinaire qui va amener alors
révocation la place nationale
simplement il vient de demander leurs
rêves et de leur révocation à l'instant
chez nos confrères de france télévisions
mais bien sûr si vous voulez l'autorité
leur hiérarchie
il va vouloir sacrifier
ceci pour mieux masquer cela est le seul
à c'est sur quoi vous m'interrogez c'est
à dire quel est le climat qui
conviendrait de modifier pour éviter
qu'on ait de tels excès fort regrettable
commis à l'avenir alors les excès vous
ne les éviterez jamais mais par contre
ce que l'on peut commencer à pondérer
c'est le mauvais signal envoyé par le
ministère de l'intérieur à ses troupes
c'est à dire un signal du tout
sécuritaire
quoi qu'il en coûte voyez actuellement
il ya une mauvaise musique qui
s'instaure qui vise à dire que les
libertés publiques doivent passer au
second rang après la sécurité et que
pour garantir la sécurité tout moyen est
bon aux fins d'arriver au résultat et à
quoi on arrive en introduisant cette
confusion dans les consignes qu'on donne
aux forces de l'ordre
on arrive à de l'insécurité à une
insécurité
comme je le disais tout à l'heure en
présence des forces de l'ordre
ça a commencé avec le gilet jaune ça se
prolonge maintenant et entre temps
beaucoup d'épisodes malheureux se sont
produits mais aussi une insécurité
quant à la crédibilité des enquêtes
parce que précisément elle repose sur
des procès-verbaux dont la véracité va
être relus à l'aune des événements qui
se déroulent
merci merci qu'armand de 16,2
voir était avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on continue de réagir à cette
actualité du jour avec alina couric
député agir ensemble deuxième
circonscription de la marne
joaquim pueyo maire ps d'alençon florian
philippot président des patriotes
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
condamnation unanime après cette vidéo
choc de cet homme agressé florian
philippot je voudrais vous faire réagir
notamment sur l'idée véhiculée par
carbon de 16 à l'instant c'est tout un
climat qu'il faut modifier les libertés
publiques passe après la sécurité
aujourd'hui c'est votre opinion
également il ya un énorme problème si
vous voulez on a bien vu depuis
depuis les gilet jaune on a vu ensuite
dans les manifestations de pompiers de
soignants de l'attestation retraite je
me suis même de manifestations de
policiers contre d'autres policiers qui
avaient une dérive en france
si vous voulez il ya une véritable
dérive on a vu des yeux le crever des
mains arrachées sans que ça coûtait
beaucoup d'émotion chez les ministres de
l'intérieur à l'époque et et des
comportements vis-à-vis de manifestants
pourtant très pacifique et est
absolument inadmissible en france donc
là il vient écouter les policiers vont
évidemment être révoqué le faut mais il
faut faire un grand grand ménage il faut
réinstaurer un principe c'est que nous
sommes dans un pays où il faut traiter
dignement les citoyens voilà ya beaucoup
de policiers drames qui font très bien
leur travail
alors pour eux pour l'honneur de ces
policiers de ces gendarmes et pour la
tranquillité de notre pays en général
il faut faire le ménage et et retirer
les musiciens parmi les policiers voyez
mais ça c'est à l'état et c'est aux
ministres comme ministre ou président
implique de montrer l'exemple au plus
haut niveau et donc il faut commencer
par retirer cette loi absurde incroyable
scandaleuse la sécurité globale
quiconque qui comporte l'article 24 dont
on parle beaucoup qui est inadmissible
antidémocratique au possible mais
également l'article 22 sur les drones et
autres joyeusetés
il faut retirer cette loi et il faut
redonner la peau
si vidéo français de manifester de se
rassembler et d'être des citoyens
adultes dans des conditions normales et
acceptable lina couric vous vous
souvenez plus tôt cette loi sécurité qui
a été voté à l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que s'interroge
qui s'est passé parce que sans cette
vidéo
cette affaire n'aurait pas été révélé on
apprend d'ailleurs par la même occasion
que le premier ministre un sort une
commission pour une nouvelle écriture de
cet article 24,1 très controversé
aujourd'hui ce soir est ce que vous
soutenez avec autant de force
cette loi est cet article 24
alors oui il faut déjà mettre une
première choses au clair il y à la loi
sécurité globale eliès qui s'est passé
récemment la loi sécurité globale
aujourd'hui ne permet pas les tristes
événements que nous avons vu aujourd'hui
circulé sur internet et la loi sécurité
globale l'article 24 n'interdit pas de
filmer les policiers lorsqu'ils sont en
intervention lors de manifestations ça
n'est pas dans le texte
donc il faut il faut quand même remettre
aussi les choses en contexte
il vient de se passer quelque chose de
très grave par ailleurs le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est déjà exprimé sur la
question et mais la loi sécurité globale
n'interdira pas de filmer les policiers
et je me suis exprimée par ailleurs en
juillet dernier dans une tribune parce
qu'il est important aussi de permettre
la publicité des sanctions parce que on
a besoin de recréer de la confiance
entre les forces de l'ordre et nos
concitoyens et qu'il est important qu'il
de faire comprendre qu'il n'y a pas
d'impunité aujourd'hui et joaquim pueyo
cet article 24 vous êtes en partie
d'accord peut-être avec kahina comique
où il faut à tout prix s'en débarrasser
aujourd'hui est la preuve avec cette
affaire il ya quelques semaines j'étais
encore députés du groupe socialiste et
le groupe a voté contre cette loi
notamment en rappelant l'article 24 mois
je pense que la transparence et doit
être de mise parce que si on n'est pas
transparent même de l'heure
que le maintien d'ordre est difficile ça
va créer beaucoup de suspicion beaucoup
de controverses
on le voit malheureusement dans ce cas
de figure pour moi je suis pour une
transparence
je suis par exemple pour que chaque
policier également une caméra sur lui
parce que effectivement lui également
il peut être agressé c'est une preuve
lorsque effectivement il ya une enquête
judiciaire do we pour la transparence
et puis il ya un problème du maintien de
l'ordre moi vous savez j'ai dirigé les
plus gros établissements pénitentiaires
de france touré mérogis fresnes et j'ai
toujours indiqué lorsque des
surveillants et en difficulté lorsqu'il
devait agir pour maintenir l'ordre
il ya un problème de recrutement des
personnels il ya un problème de la
formation la formation continue elle
n'est pas suffisante
le drame dans la police nationale et
loire les policiers que je rencontre et
les syndicats je suis maire d'une ville
me disent que la plaque ya pas
suffisamment jour de deux formations au
rck le m lannes lord c'est compliqué on
le voit très bien on l'a vu place de la
république lorsqu'il faut faire partir
effectivement des centaines de personnes
ce n'est pas simple donc c'est des
actions délicate mais effectivement les
comportements tels qu'on lui convient de
voir sont pas acceptables dans l'état de
droit comme la france dans une
démocratie
je pense que le ministre a pris des
décisions et je crois qu'il a raison
il ya une enquête judiciaire qui doit
être faite également et puis on attendra
bien sûr les décisions enquête
judiciaire mais transparence formation
et peut-être également un recrutement
plus adaptée par rapport aux eaux à la
sécurité qui a évolué parce que le
maintien de l'ordre maintenant il est
différent de ce qu'on a pu vivre ya une
vingtaine d'années si l'on vient
philippon gérald darmanin qui demande
effectivement la révocation à des
policiers
ce soir le ministre de l'intérieur qui
sera auditionné devant l'assemblée
nationale concernant les violences des
forces de l'ordre en général
aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière est
ce que vous vous tenez cet homme comme
responsable en tout cas le ministre
qu'il est comme en partie responsables
de ce type d'événements
le lisent l'intérieur est toujours
responsable de ce qui se passe dans son
ministère à principe mais ont une fois
avoir l'honnêteté aussi le dire que ça
n'a pas commencé avec le gérald darmanin
on se souvient sous christophe castaner
en fait c'est une dérive une dérive
l'attend depuis
plusieurs années où on a quand même
s'ils voulaient des gouvernements qui
donne le sentiment qu'ils font de la
liberté des français de s'exprimer donc
d'exprimer une opposition de manifester
de se rassembler 1 considère cela comme
un problème un problème alors qu'en
démocratie ça devrait être absolument un
droit ça devrait absolument normal on
voit que les manifestations sont plus
jeunes vont plus souvent restreinte
interdite
je le sais un comme responsable comme
chef de parti politique on essaie de
manifester très pacifiquement je vous
rassure pour l'exiger des moyens pour
l'hôpital et ça on nous a interdit on
nous fait les arrêtés préfectoraux
d'interdiction alors on doit les
attaques et on va faire des référés on
les gagne et puis on nous interdit
ensuite quand ça bouge il faut que ce
soit statique et ça tout ça est délirant
et c'est de pire en tirer s'il voulait
forcément forcément ça imprègne le
portement de certains policiers de
certains gendarmes qui ensuite se
croient tout permis et ça vient de là
donc c'est toute une culture qu'il faut
changer est ce que la france est encore
véritablement une démocratie
je crois que non c'est là le problème
s'ils voulaient le problème c'est qu'on
n'est plus aujourd'hui véritablement une
démocratie on le voit bien et donc ça se
traduit par des comportements comme ça
donc je pense que changer de ministre ou
auditionné mise ne changera pas grand
chose c'est vraiment une véritable
révolution politique qui doit attendre
la france et qui sera nécessaire à ina
couric la france n'est plus un pays
démocratique
je n'ai absolument pas d'accord avec ça
bien sûr que la france est un pays
démocratique et même pendant les
périodes d'état d'urgence même pendant
la période de deux 2 de confinement de
de couvre feu il a toujours été rappelé
qu'il y avait la possibilité de
manifester même quand on ne pouvait pas
rassemblé plus de 10 personnes en
extérieur les autorisations
manifestez-vous déclarée en préfecture
si vous manifestez
c'est cela va était encore possible donc
moment je ne suis pas d'accord et ça
reste un pays démocratique
c'est un pays dans lequel les français
nos concitoyens ont toujours le droit de
s'exprimer
il y a eu des violences qui sont
effectivement choquantes
de la part de policiers ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui la doctrine du ministère de
l'intérieur où une volonté d'empêcher
nos concitoyens de s'exprimer ce sont
des cas qui doivent être sanctionnées
qui sont précisément inacceptable que et
qui doivent évidemment avoir une vraie
réponse ferme mais bien sûr que non je
ne suis pas d'accord avec le fait que
nous n'ayons pas nous n'aurions pas le
droit de nous exprimer dans un pays
comme la france
joaquim pueyo votre opinion sur ce point
effectivement de beaucoup plus de plus
en plus de gens pensent que la france
est de moins en moins démocratique est
ce que c'est votre avis également
je suis d'accord avec macaulay ou pas
dire que la france est sauvée moi je
crois pas avec d'autres pays la france
n'est pas moins démocratique que les
autres pays à la liberté de la presse
qu'il faut absolument maintenir
l'indépendance de la justice
on a un régime bien sûr présidentielle
mais avec un parlement qui doit jouer
également un rôle
donc je peux pas dire que la france
n'est pas un pays démocratique
simplement je pense qu'il ya des
comportements qu'on ne peut pas accepter
effectivement lorsqu'on exerce des
fonctions telles que par rapport aux
forces de l'ordre
mais je crois également fait honnête de
le redire elodie à monsieur philippe au
mois je je discute beaucoup des
policiers et des jeunes policiers qui
sont en région parisienne et croyez moi
que c'est pas sain croyez moi c'est
difficile également
ils sont constamment insultés menacés
voire agresser je voudrais dire qu'il ya
des milliers de policiers qui sont
agressés par an la livre est qu'il ya
quelques policiers bien ils ont pas
suffisamment de discernement et
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas suffisamment
a les qualités pour exercer ses
fonctions par conséquent moi je crois
beaucoup à la pédagogie
je crois beaucoup aussi à la sanction
lorsque c'est nécessaire
d'ailleurs chaque année il ya des
policiers qui passe devant le conseil de
discipline parce que ils ont pas été
suffisamment professionnels dans leur
dans leurs actions quotidiennes mais une
grande majorité des policiers croyez moi
font leur travail
moi je suis dans un département plutôt
rurale nous les difficultés qu'on voit
actuellement on les rend compte panneaux
sur le terrain que ce soit dans les
milieux rural dans les vignes
nous avons la police donc je pense qu'il
ya un travail effectivement
faire mais on a recruté beaucoup de
policiers en quelques mois parce qu on a
créé des postes supplémentaires qui
étaient nécessaires
et la question que je me pose
profondément est ce que on les a bien
formés et bien je crois pas voilà c'est
un la formation pour moi c'est très
important lorsque effectivement on doit
manier le maintien de l'ordre parce
qu'on sait très bien que nous avons des
manifestations
je parle pas de ce cas de figure qui est
qui et qui est absolument inacceptable
quelquefois vous avez des manifestants
très violent et c'est difficile pour la
police effectivement de les maintenir et
c'est vous restez tous les trois avec
nous pour commenter l'autre grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée les
annonces de jean castex tout le service
après vente
après l'allocution d'emmanuel macron
mardi soir le premier ministre entouré
de ses ministres du travail de la santé
et de la culture voici ce qu'il faut
retenir de cette allocution ce matin
avec notre reporter katia technique
avant de retrouver nos trois invités
jean castex prévoit un retour par étapes
à une vie presque normale à des fêtes de
fin d'année en famille suivant la baisse
des contaminations alors qu'en est il
les magasins non essentiels rouvriront à
partir du 28 novembre mais avec un
protocole renforcé 8 m² par client ou
par couple ou par personnes accompagnées
d'un enfant avec un système de comptage
pour les magasins de plus de 400 mètres
carrés
les auto écoles pourront poursuivre
certaines activités ainsi que les
visites immobilière qui vont reprendre
mais pas de bonne surprise concernant
les bars et les restaurants qui ne
rouvriront que le 20 janvier
mais jean castex compte accompagner
cette filière est créée par exemple une
année de la gastronomie en 2021 je
propose de l'écouter
nous allons très fortement accompagner
les professionnels de ce secteur
financièrement d'abord en veillant à ce
qu'ils puissent tenir le coup j'y
reviendrai
nous allons les aider par des marques de
solidarité en recourant le plus possible
à la vente de repas à emporter en leur
portant une attention individualisé
territoire par territoire en leur
offrant aussi des perspectives
d'abord en préparant avec eux
les conditions de réouverture dès que ce
virus sera maîtrisée et cela arrivera
la règle des 20 km et des trois heures
ne doit pas être réservée à la famille
et aux amis mais bien aux sports
individuels à la chasse et à la pêche le
15 décembre les activités extrascolaires
en intérieur et en extérieur vont
reprendre en revanche les salles de
sport resteront fermés 15 décembre aussi
une bonne nouvelle pour les lieux
culturels les salles de spectacle les
salles de concert et bien elles
rouvriront en revanche avec une
contrainte 1 celle de respecter le
couvre-feu à 21h les spectacles devront
être terminés concernant les lieux de
culte la jauge de 30 personnes est en
vigueur en revanche elle pourrait être
augmenté au fil du temps et également de
la capacité des établissements religieux
et concernant les stations de ski bien
jean castex à inciter les français à
aller y respirer l'air pur
en revanche pas de ce qui pour le moment
puisque les remontées mécaniques seront
interdites
voilà ce qu'on peut retenir de cette
conférence de presse de jean castex
oui nous sommes donc toujours avec nos
trois invités à ina conry député agir de
la deuxième circonscription de la marne
joaquim pueyo maire ps d lanson et
florian philippot président des
patriotes alors effectivement ce qui a
beaucoup attiré mêmes fait sourire c'est
vrai aujourd'hui c'est cette affaire des
stations de ski en qui vont rester
ouvertes mais alors sont remontées
mécaniques bon courage pour porter les
skis je vous propose tout d'abord
d'écouter le premier ministre avant de
vous faire réagir
notre objectif est de permettre un
retour par étapes à une vie plus normale
de vous permettre de passer les fêtes de
fin d'année avec vos proches tout en
limitant au maximum le risque de reprise
épidémique
il est donc prématuré de parler de
déconfinement il est surtout
indispensable de ne pas baisser la garde
rina couric c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
beaucoup d'ironie sur cette affaire des
stations de ski ouvertes sont les les
remonter
beaucoup parlent d' absurdistan c'était
un petit peu les blagues qu'on voyait
sur les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui quel
est votre avis il ya de la cohérence
dans ses annonces pour vous je pense que
tout d'abord dans un premier temps il ya
la grosse déception des dames en des
gérants de ces stations qui s'attendait
à pouvoir démarrer une saison qui va
arriver finalement avec quand même un
mois de décalage ce qui est énorme et
évidemment lorsqu'on essaie de se
déplacer par foyer on aurait pu imaginer
finalement que certains essaient de
trouver des moyens de s'adapter des
protocoles sanitaires avaient été en ce
sens déjà proposé par par les
professionnels aujourd'hui c'est pas le
choix du gouvernement
je pense que il y a eu il n'y a pas que
ce ce choix là qui a pu décevoir une
grande partie de nos professionnels et
notamment les restaurateurs qui
aujourd'hui sont encore dans la tente
la tante de devoir peut-être après le 20
janvier potentiellement si jamais les
conditions sont réunies
ça reste encore des doutes des
questionnements bien que moi ce que
j'aurais pu entrer saluer du dernier
discours du président de la république
c'est d'avoir donné des échéances ça
permet quand même d'essayer d'anticiper
et de s'organiser
si les conditions le permettent mais
derrière la grosse déception que ce soit
les stations de ski que ce soit les
restaurateurs il va ya il va falloir
avoir en tout cas leur apporter des
réponses et un accompagnement bien plus
fort que ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui
c'est certain et surtout beaucoup de
français- recherche de la cohérence
parce que beaucoup craignent aussi la
concurrence déloyale les stations de ski
vont rester ouvertes en suisse
on va regarder un petit peu ce qui se
passe sur une infographie avec les
voisins européens berlin qui plaide pour
une interdiction des vacances de ski
jusqu'au 10 janvier
un gars merkel qui dit clairement que
c'est pas gagné elle va essayer mais
c'est pas gagné puisque l'autriche
aimerait bien elle rouvrira temps pour
noël
florian philippot il ne faudrait pas
fixé une règle commune
dans l'union européenne pour éviter la
concurrence déloyale eh bien regardez le
seul pays qu'il n'y ait pas dans l'union
européenne c'est la suisse et ils
ouvrent leur station ils vont récolter
le pactole est en fait nous on a obéi il
a une demande allemande qui
effectivement vous l'avez dit
l'allemagne en ce moment préside le
conseil européen pour six mois et bien à
demander à l'union européenne
d'interdire d'obtenir la fermeture des
stations de ski dans toutes les lignes
rentables donc pas la suisse jusqu'au
moins au 10 janvier donc encore voilà
une de nos conséquent une des
conséquences de notre appartenance à
cette structure supranationale
décidément sous domination allemande
monsieur castex n'est pas une absurdité
près puisque par ailleurs il veut une
grande année de la gastronomie en 2021
mais encore faudrait-il qu'ils encore
des restaurants en france en 2021
une récente étude a montré que deux sur
trois pourrait fermer
donc si vous voulez c'est une
catastrophe qu'il a annoncé d'abord tous
ces présupposés scientifique est
salutaire repose sur la pseudo science
de l'obscurantisme de la bouillie le
confinement les couvre-feux les jours je
les machins comme ça les pays qui ont
réussi dans le monde corée du sud et
japon la suède et c'est parce que
monsieur verrons nous dit il ya des
morts en ce moment suite j'ai vérifié
moi même il y en a eu deux lions comme
il est bien sont les pays qui ne sont
pas dans les restrictions comme cela les
confinements extra n'ont pas d'effet il
a été démontré que la courbe s'était
déjà inversée en octobre-novembre
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays européens
à peu près en même temps avant que les
couvre-feux et confinement et puisse
puisse provoquer un cas un éventuel
impact donc ça tue des secteurs
économiques entiers
ça met au chômage des gens sacré dépôt
sacré les désastres également sanitaire
parce que des maladies qui ne sont plus
détecté on sait que notamment dans le
domaine du cancer en tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
on a un lien journal le monde sort un
article ce soir doublement des
tentatives de suicide chez les
adolescents par rapport à l'année
dernière donc des astres psychique aussi
nos libertés sont complètement massacré
ces couvre feu non monsieur 4 il nous a
même pas annoncé qu'après le 20 janvier
il ya plus de couvre-feu il a simplement
dit qu'il serait éventuellement des cas
les bons la condition que d'ici là on
nous dise pas qu'ils aient une troisième
ou une quatrième vague
donc si vous voulez faut arrêter avec
tout ça vous donner les moyens à la
santé il faut cibler les personnes
vulnérables
il faut être malin comme l'allemagne qui
a installé comme des purificateurs d'air
dans les
deux classes ce qu'on n'a pas été
capable de faire il faut aller vers le
traitement le traitement j'aimerais
qu'on écoute davantage ceux qui prônent
notamment lé hydroxy chloroquine qui ont
été mis de côté pour le sombre en raison
de conflits d'intérêts et et qu'on est
con des cons film totalement la france
et nos libertés parce que sinon le pays
va mourir va mourir tout simplement l'or
à vendre ça va j'ai rejoint kim plus
haut sur ce thème je voudrais qu'on
aille à marseille à près de deux mille
commerçants de tous les départements du
sud est de la région paca se sont réunis
pour manifester sur le vieux port les
restaurateurs cafetiers ou encore
hôteliers ont protesté contre les
dispositions gouvernementales après
avoir appris qu'il ne pourrait pas
rouvrir avant le 20 janvier des mesures
jugé injuste et incohérente rappelons qu
aucune information concernant lé bar zen
et discothèques encore été dévoilé des
annonces qui passe mal donc à
l'ouverture de la saison hivernale
écouter les nouvelles se succèdent et
sont de plus en plus mauvaise puisque
m'a entendu le président qui souhaitait
une ouverture des statures que le 20
janvier dans un premier temps
aujourd'hui notre premier ministre nous
annonçait la fermeture non pas des
stations mais des remontées mécaniques
donc ça veut dire que au delà de 2 des
restaurants qu'on a pu entendre qu'ils
ont représenté ici aussi c'est toute une
économie montagnarde qui est en train de
mourir qu'on fait mourir après avoir
pensé pouvoir travailler dans des
conditions à peu près correct pour
sauver les meubles en ayant impliqué
tous les protocoles comme l'imposé
aujourd'hui on se trouve à l'ouverture
d'une saison d'hiver qui est qui
représente 80% de notre chiffre
d'affaires et on se trouve dans le
l'impasse est la plus absolue puisque
nous empêche d'ouvrir le commerce c'est
difficile de 2 comme on appelle ça de
décrire la souffrance et le
le malheur dans laquelle les métiers de
la nuit son temps de de vivre en ce
moment et depuis neuf mois rien entendu
avec des mesures imposées et la
difficulté de de survivre en fête au
port ou pour les exploitants et pour les
les employés c'est trop dur c'est vous
c'est trop dur joaquim pueyo viens
d'entendre ce restaurateur évidemment
qui souffrent florian philippon qui
vient de dire oui trop prudents trop de
restrictions est ce que vous partagez
également cet avis écoutez moi je
rencontre évidemment des restaurateurs
je rencontre des responsables
discothèque sur mon territoire bien sûr
il y sont en souffrance et ils
souhaitent ouvrir le plus vite possible
cependant et un équilibre
quand je vois effectivement le nombre de
morts en france plus de 50 mille morts
plus de cent mille morts en europe
c'est pas aussi simple que cela régler
cette situation ici on nous démontre
effectivement que la circulation du
virus s'accélère lorsqu'il ya un flux de
population ça me paraît normal que les
gouvernements prennent des dispositions
d'ailleurs on peut regarder que dans
tous les pays d'europe même pour ceux
qui au départ n'était pas pour le
confinement cadets l'angleterre ils ont
changé de stratégie au départ j'étais
contre le confinement à présent du
combiné comme en irlande comme dans les
pays de galles caetera et on voit
également nos pays voisins qui ont dû
reprendre des restrictions plus dures
l'allemagne a décidé de de renforcer
encore les restrictions
alors moi je vais pas attaquer le
gouvernement parce que je me dis est ce
que nous si elle était au gouvernement
nous les socialistes est ce qu'on ferait
mieux je ne sais pas parce qu'on est
obligé de tenir compte à la fois de la
santé l'économie juhan important d'eau
et un espèce d'équilibré qu'il faut
atteindre la l'equilibre le président de
la république et premiers ministres ont
indiqué voilà les clients
on va d confiné progressivement on va
alléger les restrictions 15 décembre
et si effectivement le qu'ovide
s'atténue eh bien on pourra encore aller
plus loin alors moi je peux comprendre
effectivement que quelquefois il ya un
manque de cohérence sur les stations
reçu pas allégé des montagnes mais sur
les stations de sports d'hiver c'est
vrai j'ai du mal à comprendre
de dire vous pouvez aller dans les
stations mais vous pouvez pas faire du
ski c'est comme moi dans mes forêt on
peut faire des randonnées sa cause aucun
problème de se promener et faire des
randonnées pendant plusieurs kilomètres
donc c'est vrai que quelquefois il ya un
problème de cohérence mais franchement
je le dis tel que je pense le fait qu'il
ya quand même une échéance c'est plutôt
positif de dire 'voilà première étape du
caucase descend en deuxième étape
jusqu'au 15 janvier
ça donne quand même des perspectives
mais ce qui est important et je jure je
rejoins monsieur philippe ou lorsqu'il
dit attention beaucoup de restaurateurs
risque de fermer papa des deux tiers moi
je rencontre la fédération de
l'hôtellerie me dis peut-être 30%
c'est énorme c'est considérable parce
que autour du restaurant il ya le lien
social
il ya l'économie il ya tout un tout une
activité
je pense que le fonds de soutien que
vient de décider le gouvernement moi
j'attends concrètement si le fonds de
soutien va permettre de sauver nous
entreprises notamment les restaurants
les discothèques également les
entreprises liées à l'événementiel
il ya eu des chicots d'annoncer 10000
euros maintenant on va à 20% du chiffre
d'affaires
et moi je demande aux restaurateurs qui
qui sont sur nos territoires de
m'informer parce que la normandie la
région à laquelle j'appartiens on est en
train de mettre un fond de soutien
complémentaire parce que pour les villes
moyennes
l'activité de commercial activités
économiques liées également au tourisme
elle est fondamentale pour l'avenir dont
je suis je comprends les mesures de
restrictions actuelles qu'elles sont
progressives et j'ose espérer que locaux
vides pour a stagné d'ailleurs ceux qui
étaient contre confinement ils le sont
un petit peu moins quand même parce que
si vous n'avez pas confiné moi je vois
le pit à la mention on avait quasiment
80 % de lits occupés par des malades de
covin dans l'animation et le directeur
d'hôpital le disait monsieur le
président dans une semaine on pourra
plus accueillir nos malades et le valais
tu connais bien et bien ça a permis de
stabiliser on a diminué le nombre de
malades dans les services de réanimation
ça ce sont des chiffres alors si mal
aimé du tout leur donnez moi on va faire
aussi regina coric à une akory pas remis
les mesures préconisées par emmanuel
macron est reprise par jean castex matin
cette proposition de loi d'ailleurs
défendu par votre groupe à l'assemblée
nationale hier pour isoler les patients
du coc vide avec contrainte a dit le
chef de l'état est ce que vous ne
craignez pas quand même une
infantilisation des français est ce
qu'on a vraiment toujours besoin d'être
puni savez on nous reprochera toujours
un moment donné de le faire quand on le
fait de ne pas faire si on ne le fait
pas c'est carrément donné le groupe agir
ensemble a déposé une proposition de loi
en faisant plusieurs plusieurs
recommandations des recommandations qui
ont été reprises nous avons également
écrit au premier ministre et certains
éléments ont été repris et on s'en
réjouit notamment sur l'augmentation du
1 km qui passe à 20 km et ça on le salue
et également sur effectivement le
confinement parce que on parle beaucoup
des libertés individuelles
en cette période de crise sanitaire
parce qu'on dit qu'on peut plus sortir à
telle heure on ne peut plus se déplacer
à tel endroit etc
mais un moment donné si on veut lutter
contre cette pandémie qui est mondial il
faut aussi que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités il ya des
recommandations et puis il ya des règles
ce n'est un fonds anti lisez personne
que de vouloir protéger nos concitoyens
c'est à dire que lorsque vous avez une
personne qui serait donc testée positive
à la copie de 19
la recommandation c'est donc d'isoler
cette personne de qu'elle se confine
tout simplement pour se faire suivre et
soigner et protéger ses proches
son entourage ne pas se rendre au
travail si vous êtes malade
si vous présentez des symptômes est donc
resté restez chez vous effectivement il
y à une mesure dissuasive qui est une
une amende en contravention catégorie 5
à la qui peut aller jusqu'à 2500 euros
il ya aussi une une indemnisation
journalière de 30 euros par jour
puisqu'on sait très bien que si vous
confiné et vous ne pouvez plus aller
travailler il ya aussi évidemment des
conséquences économiques
et c'est de pouvoir aussi rester à
domicile avec un accompagnement et la
mobilisation de la réserve civique pour
pouvoir accompagner ces personnes
au quotidien parce qu'on sait très bien
que tout le monde n'a pas tout on n'a
pas la même vie via les familles
nombreuses sont les familles
monoparentales
il y a enfin bref des parcours de vie
totalement différent et il va falloir
être en capacité à accompagner c'est
proposer un maximum d'outils un maximum
de solutions si on veut véritablement
une fine et vivre avec le virus
quand on est confiné on ne vit pas avec
le virus ne vit pas du tout donc si on
veut vivre avec
oui des mesures concrètes qui nous
permettent au quotidien à chacun de
continuer à maintenir une activité
économique une activité professionnelle
ou sportives et permettre en tout cas à
ceux qui sont malades de se protéger on
doit s'interroger sur notre manière de
gérer des épidémies de manière plus
générale on parle lui on parle de l'aco
vide mais de manière plus générale on
doit s'interroger est ce qu'on sait
faire face à des épidémies en france et
on voit bien que c'est compliqué même
dans des pays occidentaux comme comme la
france et donc il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver aujourd'hui des solutions pour
permettre à chacun de continuer à vivre
sans et en évitant en même temps de la
propagation du virus
florian philippot vous avez l'air de
lever les yeux au ciel de pire et cinq
minutes mais non mais attendez moi je
dis je dis aux gens de se mobiliser de
sortir dans la rue parce que si vous
voulez quand j'entends ce genre de
discours de d'apprentis sorciers
atlantique tateurs qui nous explique on
va jouer toute notre vie maintenant avec
des couvre-feux des restrictions masque
à l'extérieur l' isolement obligatoire
quand même et puis j'ai vu ce projet de
passeport sanitaire a lancé par des
compagnies aériennes et des états avec
la vaccination obligatoire sinon pour
ait pu prendre l'avion et puis demain
vous pourrez pu rentrer dans un
restaurant entrées au cinéma rentrée au
théâtre on entend déjà ce genre de teint
gris mais malheureusement si on n'en est
plus au stade de l'imagination ou du
chantage
on en est au stade de la réalité et on
voit en face des gens qu'on filme en
taule à des apprentis dictateurs comme
ça qui font peu de cas de la liberté
individuelle et qui en plus grande des
politiques qui ne fonctionne pas
renseignez vous renseignez vous les pays
vous me citez des pictons fédé
confinement à côté l'italie l'espagne la
belgique effectivement roi lui c'est les
pires résultats en termes de mortalité
du monde donc il faut se poser des
questions l'argentine est en confinement
puis sept mois ça fait sept mois que la
mortalité augmente par contre les pays
intelligents qui ont elles beaucoup
maintenant ils ont aucun aucun
renseignez vous y compris l'allemagne
d'ailleurs n'a fait de confinement ça ne
fonctionne pas ce
et ça a baissé vous disiez tout à
l'heure effectivement ça a baissé
heureusement en octobre novembre
mais on sait maintenant que saab et ses
avants et par tous a baissé au même
moment au même moment aux pays bas alors
qu'il a fallu tout confinement parce
qu'il ya une dynamique propre du virus
alors on doit investir massivement dans
les lits d'hôpital au lieu d'en fermer
encore 3800 comme on l'a fait en 2019 le
sou emmanuel macron et 110 milles depuis
25 ans
on doit travailler sur le traitement
doit cibler nos personnes âgées l'âge
moyen de l'âge médian des morts du
courant d'un virus et 84 ans donc on
sait qui est le mien il faut en prendre
soin mais il faut arrêter cette folie
totale parce qu'on n'en sortira jamais
et vous dites madame il faut s'occuper
de toutes les épidémies effectivement
vous avez raison votre raisonnement il
sera utilisée demain pour n'importe
quelle épidémie de grippe à un peu
sérieuse ou n'importe quelle épidémie tu
es qu on nous mettra en permanence des
restrictions des restrictions des
restrictions et on détruira les secteurs
économiques entiers et on détruira
l'éducation notre pays sa culture son
âme son âme
donc les gens doivent se mobiliser de
nouveau l'histoire c'est partout des
rassemblements en france
florian philippot à joaquim pueyo
écouter est-ce que moi j'écoute quand
même les médecins
j'écoute que les scientifiques qui nous
disent que le confinement a été utile
pour maîtriser la circulation du coni
d'ailleurs je veux dire je ne sais pas
s'il ya des pays exemplaire est ce que
par exemple on peut considérer que le
brésil est un pays exemplaire quand je
vois les noms de milliers de morts le
mexique que deux cent mille morts papa
des états unis donc je sais pas s'il ya
des pays dans plaire je crois que chaque
pays essaye de trouver des solutions
pour maîtriser cette épidémie qui fait
quand même des morts qui fait que plus
de 200000 morts en europe
cinquante mille morts en france est une
ville de 50 milles qui est d'habitants a
disparu en 1 an ces quand même c'est pas
une situation simple
donc moi j'ai beaucoup de mesures j'ai
connu le oui après si on peut avoir des
différences de stratégie et moi j'écoute
des médecins et le corps médical quand
même nous a dit que le confinement et
les restrictions ondres malgré tout
éviter à ce que le virus s'y s'amplifie
tout du moins dans les pays qui ont
appliqué ce genre de restrictions
genève après je suis d'accord sur l'
isolement
il faut pas stigmatiser les malades
attention de mettre une obligation pour
isoler les personnes faut que tous les
accompagner au plus tôt les aider parce
qu'il ya un problème de déontologie et
d'éthique professionnelle
moi je ne veux pas savoir si mon voisin
alko vide s'il est isolé cetera
donc il ya un problème là de liberté
fondamentale qui va se poser
et là je suis d'accord avec monsieur
philippe haut sur ce point merci en tout
cas tous les 3 florian philippot aïnats
couric je rectifie puyoô d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
commenter donc ces deux grands titres de
l'actualité est toujours en france c'est
une première une gilet jaune indemniser
l'état a reconnu responsable des
blessures causées été reconnu
responsable des plaisirs des blessures
causées la victime était touchée par un
tir de l bd lors d'une manifestation le
9 février 2010 9 à lyon est détaillé
avec les îles à saraf la décision du
tribunal administratif de lyon a été
rendu public ce mercredi
la justice a reconnu la responsabilité
sans faute de l'état
la victime blessée à la jambe par un tir
de l bd s'est vu accorder une
indemnisation de 800 euros
une première en france de nombreux
manifestants qui ont été touchés par des
tirs de l bd n'ont pas nécessairement
déposé plainte et non pas en fait voulu
prendre le risque si on peut dire de
d'entamer une procédure judiciaire
800 euros obtenus contre les 10000
demandé la question est sur toutes les
lèvres pourquoi un tel écart entre la
somme réclamée et celles accordées
traditionnellement le juge administratif
est plutôt protecteur des deniers de
l'état donc il indemnise pas énormément
ça on peut le regretter
la seconde chose qu'on peut aussi
regretter c'est que il n'est pas pris en
compte
en tout cas insuffisamment la question
du retentissement psychologique puisque
dans son jugement il a dit qu'un discret
retentissement psychologique pour la
victime c'est pas vraiment ça la victime
en l'occurrence mélodie elle c'est pas
rien de se prendre un tir de lanceur de
balles de défense dans le dans la jambe
alors qu'on se contente de manifester
voilà c'est derrière chaque fois qu'elle
est allée manifester
elle est allée avec la boule au ventre
et ça en fait ça doit être traduit par
une indemnisation qui est à la hauteur
du dommage tout simplement
l'avocat de la gilet jaune souhaite
aujourd'hui voir le parquet de lyon
rouvrir une enquête notamment pour
retrouver le policier auteur du tir
il n'est pas le seul ça fait plus d'un
an et demi et la justice on est toujours
à essayer de savoir qui a tiré alors que
c'est une information à portée de main
dans le cadre d'une enquête impartiale
un autre combat a en revanche déjà été
perdue initialement la victime avait
saisi en référé le tribunal
administratif début 2019 pour obtenir en
urgence le retrait de l bd ou encore des
grenades de désencerclement elle a été
déboutée à gaza présent le blocus a
coûté 17 milliards de dollars à
l'enclavé palestinienne c'est ce
qu'indique un rapport de l'onu
en place depuis 2007 et l'arrivée du
hamas au pouvoir le blocus a fait
baisser le pib par habitant de 27%
la croissance du territoire palestinien
et de -2 5% entre 2007 et 2015 ce qui en
fait l'une des pires performances
économiques au monde
le rapporteur précise que sans sa levée
la situation ne pourra évoluer
favorablement et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis madrid avec bara
mihail directeur de stratégie sia
consulting professeur à l'université st
louis a madrid c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir barah mikaïl merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le rapport
du rapporteur de l'onu qui déclare donc
que l'unique chance de développement
pour gaza serait la fin du blocus mis en
place par israël est ce que vous
partagez vous cette analyse
oui bonsoir effectivement enfin il n'y a
pas de surprise je dirais dans ses
déclarations du rapporteur de l'onu
l'onu a nous a rappelé très
régulièrement à travers les temps le
fait que la situation d'occupation
prévalant dans les territoires
palestiniens d'ailleurs pas seulement à
gaza mais au niveau également au niveau
de la cisjordanie et quelque chose de
problématique
il n'y a pas de développement possible
sans occupation est de surcroît une
situation de blocus fait que bien
entendu l'asphyxient est totale
concernant concernant les territoires
palestiniens et concernant gaza en
particulier mais je vais dire que ce que
je suis en train de vous dire là
j'aurais pu vous le dire en 2007 en 2008
et en 2010 c'est là qu'on a un problème
de fond dans les évolutions
palestinienne c'est que non seulement la
situation de blocus est problématique
mais de surcroît le fait qu'on n'ait pas
la reconnaissance d'une entité étatique
effective qui puisse respirer qu'ils
puissent développer ses infrastructures
qui puisse réorienter ses politiques et
ses choix économiques est quelque chose
qui fait que de toute façon on pourra en
reparler dans un an dans deux ans dans
cinq ans dans dix ans tant que cette
situation d'occupation perdurera bien
sûr donc clairement ça passe par la
solution à deux états enfin il ya
beaucoup de théories en la matière mais
je crois que la solution je ne suis pas
partisan de la solution d'un état
binational je crois qu'effectivement il
est un droit droit international qui
continue à prévaloir même si sa mise en
application est compliqué je n'en
disconviens pas mais on est quand même
dans cette situation dans laquelle les
paramètres de base sont des paramètres
étatique c'est à dire que l'onu avait
reconnu en novembre 1947 laquelle l
existence ou la question de la création
d'un état palestinien à côté d'un état
israélien est depuis lors l'histoire a
été ce qu'elle a été mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que oui si on ne crée
pas deux états l'un à côté de l'autre on
serait en train d'annuler au bien la
notion de nation israélienne ou bien la
notion de nation palestinienne au bien
même ces deux ces deux notions et donc
en l'occurrence
un truc complètement hors champ
d'application du droit international d
de skill roquier requiert en
l'occurrence en matière de droit des
peuples à l'autodétermination l'onu
effectivement qui intervient qui donne
cet avis a clairement sur cette question
mais quelle est la marge de manoeuvre
vraiment réel de l'institution
aujourd'hui
alors là on est dans un problème
constant c'est à dire que bien entendu
ce qu'ils peuvent faire la différence au
niveau de l'onu ce sont les cinq membres
permanents de l'onu et on est quand même
dans un contexte dans lequel l'on voit
bien que le veto d'un des états suffit à
bloquer toute avancée en ce sens c'est à
dire que si au contraire on organise et
maintenant un vote au niveau de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
la donne serait complètement différente
et elle est on va dire que les les votes
abondant en faveur de la création d'un
état palestinien ne ferait pas de doute
à mon sens donc oui il y a un problème
de fonctionnement où il ya du moins un
blocage dû au fonctionnement à la nature
du fonctionnement de l'onu il y avait on
entendu un ascendant américain qui
oriente quand même désolé des évolutions
dans val dans le sens qui est celui
qu'il est aujourd'hui je crois qu'à
l'administration trump n'a pas beaucoup
amélioré les choses en ce sens là mais
ce n'est pas pour autant je crois que
avec l'entrée en vigueur de
l'administration de biden
il faudra s'attendre à des
développements vraiment révolutionnaire
sur la question je crois que
malheureusement il faut les palestiniens
prennent beaucoup leur mal en patience
mais on voit mal quelles sont les
horizons qui permettrait la mise en
application des principes rappelés par
l'onu dans la réalité des choses oui bah
justement c'était ma ma prochaine
question vous me croyez pas justement à
un tournant avec l'arrivée de joe biden
au niveau de cette politique justement
très honnêtement je crois que les
orientations de l'administration
américaine qu'elle ait été sous une
présidence démocrate ou sous une
présidence républicaine n'ont pas
beaucoup fait de différence concernant
la situation socio économique des
palestiniens déjà et concernant la
possibilité de se pencher de plus près
sur la possibilité de négociations
politiques et je tiens à rappeler quand
même que bien sûr les accords d'oslo
avait eu lieu sous le démocrate bill
clinton mais que ces mêmes big.little
lui-même qui finalement avait créé une
situation plus
problématique pour yasser arafat à
l'époque à une époque où il avait essayé
de rapprocher les points de vue de
yasser arafat et deux premiers ce serait
bien de l'époque ehud barak avant que de
trahir finalement il ya ces rares afat
et je ne crois pas que sous barack obama
on ait eu beaucoup de d'initiative au
beaucoup d'avancées ont même beaucoup
d'insistance sur la nécessité de créer
deux états l'un à côté de l'autre
ajoutons à cela le fait que byron et
quand même engagé maintenant parler on
va dire par les déclarations et qui ont
été prises ou par l'epa qui ont été pris
par donald chante notamment concernant
la question de jérusalem est donc en ce
sens là je ne vois absolument pas de
possible retour en arrière et je donc je
crois que au delà de la rhétorique qui
pourraient peut-être être plus aimable
concernant l'application je crois que
non le liens américano-israéliens
restera extrêmement fort et restera
plutôt orienté aux conditions
israéliennes
merci beaucoup barral mirella directeur
de strategy consulting professeur à
l'université saint louis à madrid
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir l'hommage à diego
maradona en argentine la veillée funèbre
a débuté au palais présidentiel de
buenos aires des dizaines de milliers de
fans défilent devant à la dépouille de
l'idole du football décédé mercredi à 60
ans des suites d'une crise cardiaque des
incidents survenus à l'intérieur du
palais ont forcé les autorités à retirer
le cercueil installée dans une chapelle
ardente tandis que des affrontements ont
éclaté avec la police dans les rues
alentour le président argentin alberto
fernandez a décrété trois jours de deuil
national
et parmi les moments forts de sa
carrière diego maradona était évidemment
s'en souvient champion du monde avec
l'équipe argentine c'était lors de son
match fatidique face à l'angleterre
pendant cette compétition qui a
construit sa légende en 1986 et marquez
est l'un des plus beaux buts de toute
l'histoire du football
il était aussi connu pour ses
engagements politiques retour sur une
vie à d'exception avec abdelkrim branne
et
mais grégoire douce et le che du sport
voilà comment était surnommé diego
maradona par fidel castro lui-même
ancien compagnon de route du
révolutionnaire argentin
au delà de son statut de joueur de
légende l'ancien génial numéro 10 était
également connu pour sa dimension
politique et ses choix symbolique et ce
alors qu'il était à l'apogée de sa
carrière professionnelle en 1984 il
quitte le prestigieux fc barcelone pour
rejoindre la modeste équipe de naples
l'enfant des bidonvilles de la banlieue
de buenos aires emmène le club sur le
toit de l'italie et de l'europe
après la fin de sa carrière el pibe de
oro concrétise ses engagements par le
biais de plusieurs déclarations et
rencontres fortes en 2016 il rend un
hommage appuyé à fidel castro dont il
était très proche
comme un clin d'oeil du destin le lider
maximo décède également à 25 novembre
c'est une journée horrible on m'a
annoncé la mort de celui qui était le
plus grand sans aucun doute
fidel castro est mort je suis
terriblement triste parce qu'il était
pour moi comme un second père maradona a
toujours assumé son adhésion aux idées
du socialisme latino américains après
son soutien inconditionnel à hugo chavez
il n'hésite pas à prendre la défense de
son successeur nicholas maduro tout en
égratignant au passage le président
américain donald trump
je veux dédier cette victoire à nicholas
maduro et à tout le venezuela qui
souffre actuellement à cause des shérifs
du monde que sont les yankees qui
pensent pouvoir nous mener ce tyran
qu'ils ont comme président ne nous
achètera pas l'une des dernières prises
de positions fortes de diego maradona
concerne le conflit israélo palestinien
après avoir fustigé à plusieurs reprises
le comportement de l'état hébreu il
rencontre mahmoud abbas en 2018
à l'occasion de la coupe du monde en
russie depuis l'annnonce de la mort de
celui qui est considéré comme un demi
dieu dans son pays
les hommages se multiplient dans le
monde entier preuve de son statut
exceptionnel
l'argentine a décrété trois jours de
deuil national leo messi souvent
présenté comme le successeur de diego
maradona a salué sa mémoire par ces mots
il nous quitte mais ne disparaît pas
parce que diego est éternel
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous parlerons de la conférence de
presse de jean castex le premier
ministre a déroulé ce matin le menu
annoncé par emmanuel macron une annonce
faite qui fait de boule de neige les
stations de ski seront ouvertes à noël
mais sont remontées mécaniques et puis
nous parlerons de la hongrie et de la
pologne qui tiennent tête à l'europe sur
le plan de la part du rpt de relance
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nombre de contaminés augmente chaque
semaine je pense que le système des chu
est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années les sièges sûrs on va continuer
notre des plates le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation du virus à jour et pas être
à la place du gouvernement français en
ce moment car hier que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
ont testé 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on sait la moi j'ai
un peu peur qu'on est coincé jusqu'à la
fin janvier
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des camps dit
elvia pas d'alternative au sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 26 novembre
ap le service après-vente de jean castex
qui a déroulé ce matin le menu annoncé
par emmanuel macron mardi soir le
premier ministre a dansé que les
stations de ski seront ouvertes à noël
mais sont remontées mécaniques des
décisions jugées absurdes par
l'opposition restaurateurs cafetiers ou
encore gérants de discothèques ont
manifesté à marseille contre le maintien
de la fermeture de leur établissement
budapest et varsovie affichent leur
unité face à bruxelles le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban n'a reçu
aujourd'hui son homologue polonais
mateusz morawski objectif coordonner
leur position commune pour opposer leur
veto au plan de relance de l'union
européenne et alors que l'europe et les
états unis sont en pleine deuxième vague
de kovy de la chine et ses voisins
asiatiques repartent de l'avant creusant
un peu plus l'écart avec les économies
occidentales
avec cette crise l'europe est elle
condamnée à décrocher de la croissance
mondiale pour pouvoir est il plus
difficile pour nous européens de s'en
sortir
autant de questions auxquelles jacques
sapir tentera de répondre dans son édito
échos
donald trump grassi son ex conseiller
michael flynn impliqué dans la présumée
ingérence russe lors de la
présidentielle américaine de 2000 16 une
indulgence qui referme définitivement ce
dossier alors que le président sortant
continue de contester la victoire de joe
biden du 3 novembre dernier
[Musique]
et on débute avec les derniers chiffres
du coronavirus en france santé publique
france dénombre treize 1563 4 kovy
détecté en 24 heures un chiffre en
baisse par rapport à jeudi dernier 340
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital ces
dernières 24 heures le taux de
positivité des tests s'établit désormais
à 12,2 pour cent et poursuit sa baisse
et malgré l'amélioration de la situation
jean castex n'a pas annoncé que des
bonnes nouvelles ce matin lors de son
point presse les stations de ski seront
rouvertes à noël mais sans remontées
mécaniques qui elles resteront fermés
réaction à la toussuire dans la vallée
de la maurienne en savoie où les fêtes
de fin d'année représentent entre 20 et
25% du chiffre d'affaires emilie goog h
avec luis carballo une station qui
attend la neige mais surtout des clients
la toussuire a été prise de court par
l'annoncé des manuels macron des
réservations avaient déjà été faites
pour les vacances de noël
mais ceux qui rêvaient de montagne
seront privés de ski les pertes
attendues sont conséquentes
on a deux semaines de vacances scolaires
où notre taux de remplissage était déjà
important on a eu beaucoup de
réservations
bah ça sera un manque à gagner en
chiffre d'affaires qui sera important
qui qui sera de quelques millions
d'euros quand même pour une station
comme la toussuire noël représente entre
20 et 25% du chiffre d'affaires pourtant
tous s'étaient préparés à accueillir les
skieurs dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires
l'utilisation d'un produit virucide sur
tous les équipements publics a été
généralisé dans la station utilise un
nouveau procédé pour sécuriser en fait
tout ce que l'homme contact s'est mis en
place d'ores et déjà donc on est
vraiment prêt quoi des mesures ont
également été prises dans les sites
d'hébergement de la station qui propose
plus de 14 mille lits dans diverses
structures la toussuire compte des
dizaines d'établissements hôteliers
parmi eux l'hôtel des soldats neil avec
38 chambres
son gérant frédéric
investi des sommes importantes dans le
protocole sanitaire
un protocole pour que ce soit les
interrupteurs toutes les particules il
espérait alors l'ouverture de la station
lui permettrait d'accueillir des clients
pour les fêtes de fin d'année jean
pierre vidal est un enfant du pays en
2002 il a été champion olympique de
slalom aux jeux de salt lake city
pour lui également dans la station
toutes les mesures ont été prises pour
accueillir les skieurs dans de bonnes
conditions malgré ce contexte sanitaire
difficile on est on est en place au
niveau des mesures sanitaires pas mal de
choses ont été mises en place au niveau
des remontées mécaniques
on a mis des films au niveau des
hébergements donc on est là aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir
j'ai à avoir nos clients mais les
remontées mécaniques restent à l'arrêt
et les clients comme les quatre cents
saisonniers qui travaillent normalement
à la toussuire ne viendront pas au
niveau national les conséquences
économiques de ces fermetures de
stations de ski sont importantes des
professionnels du secteur espèrent
toujours que le gouvernement revienne
sur sa décision
pour que leurs paysages reprenne vie et
offre de nouveaux les images d'une
station illuminés dans un écrin de neige
comme auparavant
alors si les remontées mécaniques
françaises seront fermés les
infrastructures suisse seront elles je
cite presque open bar selon le conseil
d'état valaisan
les stations helvétiques qui invite les
français à venir ce qui est chez elle
alors que dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne les divergences à ce
sujet sont de mise
en italie prudence pellois en autriche
les stations veulent sauver la saison
hivernale en pologne les pistes devrait
rouvrir alors en allemagne angela merkel
demandent à bruxelles d' interdire
jusqu'au 10 janvier l'accès aux stations
la chancelière allemande appelle ses
citoyens ne pas partir à l'étranger pour
les fêtes de fin d'année les précisions
de notre correspondant à berlin
un petit air olivier longué la merkel a
dit cela parce qu'elle souhaite éviter
houle récurrents
ce qui est déjà arrivé plus tôt cette
année certaines stations de ski sont
devenus les épicentres de flamber
massive du coc vide 19 le domaine
skiable de eagle par exemple en autriche
est une destination prisée dans le monde
entier et il semblerait que des
touristes et rapporter le virus dans
leurs valises
plus de 40 pays différents ont signalé
des cas de covile 19 dont la source
présumée
etait-il gueule angela merkel veut
éviter une telle situation pour les
allemands qui apprécient le ski plus
d'allemands sont friands de sports
d'hiver qu'aucune autre nationalité
européenne
marcus odeurs le président de la bavière
s'est également exprimée jeudi
il souhaite que toutes les stations de
sa région où se trouve la majeure partie
des stations de ski en allemagne reste
fermé au delà des vacances de noël et du
nouvel an afin d'éviter que ces stations
devienne l'épicentre de la propagation
du coït 19 $ pour le tri et la suisse le
risque pour l'économie et l'industrie de
la fermeture de ces stations est plus
important que le risque de contamination
le massif alpin est donc fortement clivé
quant à la politique à adopter avec les
stations de ski et nass&wind et on va
voir ce qu'en pensent les professionnels
en france pour en parler nous sommes
avec arthur reversât dirigeant du groupe
familial hôtellerie et restaurants la
folie douce
bonsoir arthur reversade merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés philippe pweto ce
directeur de l'office de tourisme les
carroz d'arâches domaine skiable grand
massif en haute-savoie bonjour à vous
aussi merci d'être avec nous alors bon
arthur reversade s'est ouvert mais pas
les remontées alors quand on connaît
votre magnifique restaurant au beau
milieu des pistes on se dit ça va être
un petit peu compliqué de grimper avec
les skis sur les épaules
quelle est votre réaction en tout cas
cette annonce du premier
est ce trop ce matin effectivement
depuis allocution de monsieur le
président on a anticipé je dirais une
fermeture nos établissements jusque
sûrement le 10 ou le vin le 20 janvier
au delà d'être une crise économique
c'est je dirais surtout une crise
sociale qui se se profile chez nous la
folie douce ses huit établissements
répartis à travers le l'arc alpin
français et c'est surtout 700
collaborateurs 700 collaborateurs que
malheureusement cette année nous ne
sommes pas en mesure d'embaucher tout de
suite ce sont donc sept cents familles
qui se retrouvent à la rue et on ne sait
pas vraiment que faire alors un philippe
preto c'est vrai qu'on se dit ouvrons la
sceller les français plutôt aisés qui
vont se retrouver sur les pistes de ski
mais arthur reversade vient de nous le
rappeler il s'agit aussi et surtout de
beaucoup d'emplois en l'occurrence 700
familles nous disent et ils vous
partager cette inquiétude vous aussi de
votre côté si on parle des emplois
saisonniers tout à fait puisque au
niveau de la station de ski on a fait un
sondage auprès des socioprofessionnels
de notre station est globalement donc
pas mal de vent pas ne seront pas
renouveler cet hiver donc près de 35 à
40% ce qui est quand même énorme et le
chiffre d'affaires des remontées
mécaniques cette période là c'est au
tour de deux millions d'euros les
stations de charme on sait qu'à peu près
pour un euro des remontées mécaniques il
ya 6 euros qui sont dépensés dans la
station donc ça fait un manque à gagner
aux alentours remontées mécaniques plus
on va dire le tissu économique de près
de 14 millions d'euros et c'est
considérable alors as-tu reversade vous
parler effectivement des conséquences
importantes économique mais sur cette
décision du premier min
avant d'ailleurs de vous faire réagir je
voudrais qu'on écoute laurent reynaud
délégué général du domaine skiable de
france les jours et donc le droit de se
rendre en station mais pas celui de
pratiquer le ski le ski une activité de
plein air que le gouvernement veut
interdire pour décourager les français
de se rendre à la montagne alors que
toutes les autres activités il serait
autorisé alors on vous imagine un petit
peu dans dans les tuyaux il ya dû avoir
une forme de lobby pour essayer de ses
stations rouve pour les fêtes
est ce que vous comprenez tout de même
cette décision du premier ministre
je pense qu on est d'une certaine
manière des des professionnels de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie de
l'entente telle montée du tourisme d'une
manière générale mais nous ne sommes pas
des professionnels ducobu je ne suis pas
un expert scientifique et donc sur cette
partie là effectivement je m'en remets à
l'état et on suit sagement leur décision
voilà ce qu'il en est par contre
effectivement je rebondis sur sur ce
sujet une station de ski sens qui ne
peut pas vivre c'est à dire que les
stations de ski
ce ne sont pas seulement le sport
d'hiver mais c'est une destination
vacances à la montagne et le ce qui fait
partie d'un maillon de la chaîne
la restauration les différents services
les différentes attractivité qui doit
dans une station on travaille tous
ensemble main dans la main et si un
maillon manquant malheureusement
l'expérience du client peut en pâtir
philippe prêteuses vous vous trouvez ça
un jeu savant c'est vrai qu'on nous
parlait 10 gaël on se souvient que
c'était un véritable cluster au début de
l'épidémie mais dans les bars de la
station et pas nécessairement sur les
pistes elle manque de cohérence cette
décision gouvernementale selon vous
c'est vrai que tout le tout le monde du
des stations de ski était très très
surpris étonné on avait des tas d
assurance mais on savait qu'il y aurait
une telle décision qui serait peut-être
positif si on nous laissait dix jours de
plus
du coup tout s'est accéléré entre le
mardi et le mercredi et ce qui fait que
du coup
non sans les remontées mécaniques c'est
vrai que ça devient plus compliqué on a
du mal à comprendre comment on pourra
peut-être à l'effet qu'ils rendront
peut-être aller faire de la raquette ou
du ski de fond et ne pas prendre les
remontées mécaniques maintenant faut
prendre ce qui reste est positif c'est
dire ben voilà les remontées mécaniques
sont fermés mais les villages et des
stations vont être accessible qu'il y
aura des activités que vous allez
pouvoir prendre l'air oxygène vous
oxygéner vous ressourcer voilà vous
évader dans cette belle nature
montagnarde pour évacuer un petit peu
tout le stress du quotidien
ça va faire du bien à tout le monde il y
aura des restaurants il y aura des
commerces ira devant la de la vente à
emporter au niveau des restaurants on le
sait mais je pense que les stations de
ski auront un rôle à jouer et si par
ailleurs ça peut protéger on va dire au
niveau des réseaux conditions sanitaires
une ouverture au mois de janvier pour
faire une saison on va dire correct que
janvier les vacances de février et
pouvoir traverser le mois de mars
peut-être qu'on dira que cette décision
n'était pas si mauvaise que ça alors on
va essayer de rester positif de dire
venez nous voir on est on a envie de
vous recevoir nos commerces seront là et
est positive on et dillon nous peut-être
que nos élus ont pris peut-être des
bonnes décisions pour protéger le ski de
de demain ou après-demain du 20 janvier
jusqu'au 30 mars au 15 avril
alors c'est tout ce qu'on vous souhaite
un parce que évidemment l'essentiel de
la saison elle se fait surtout pendant
les vacances de février
il n'empêche arthur reversade vous ne
craignez pas cette concurrence déloyale
à laquelle faisait allusion d'ailleurs
un gala merkel qui elle plaide carrément
pour une interdiction des vacances de
ski jusqu'au 10 janvier dans toute
l'europe
parce qu'on sait que l'autriche aimerait
bien sauver sa petite saison de noël la
suisse qui ne fait pas partie de
l'europe elle devrait tout simplement
rouvrir c'est compliqué on pourra gérer
pour vous cela s'est effectivement
extrêmement complexe et dans un monde
global et non sa chanteuse qui sont des
stations qui accueille en moyenne 80%
d'étrangers je me vois mal ferrer saison
de ski sans notre clientèle étrangère
et oui effectivement il nous avons peur
d'un afflux de clients qui partirait sur
des stations autrichiennes notamment ou
suisse c'est compliqué à moyen terme de
retourner capter cette clientèle pour la
ramener sur la destination france
effectivement compliqué cette confiance
à philippe et ose même inquiété de la
folie douce et où tout à fait c'est vrai
que nous on est très proche de la suisse
des collègues directeurs de stations
suisses qui ont déjà ouvert comme
verbier qui vont ouvrir pour d'autres
avec les récents d'attitude certainement
également
c'est vrai que on a une certaine
appréhension maintenant faut rester
proactif
il faut se dire que c'est à nous de les
séduire de s'adapter de faire une bonne
communication pour les prochaines
vacances et d'essayer de faire que ces
clientèles ne ne tarde pas sur les pays
étrangers je le crains plus sur les
clientèles étrangères je le crains moins
sur les clientèles françaises ces
destinations autrichiennes et suisses
voilà maintenant il faut regarder ce qui
va se passer espérer qu'il y aura une
entente européenne pour que tout le
monde le soit logé à la même enseigne
c'est ce qu'on espère et on l'avenir
nous le dira en tout cas dans l'est dans
les prochaines semaines certainement
merci arthur reversade merci également à
vous philippe tweetos les premiers
ministres hongrois et polonais affichent
leur unité face aux autres pays de
l'union européenne concernant la notion
d'état de droit les deux pays sont mis
en cause régulièrement en raison de
réformes jugées contraires aux valeurs
démocratiques
la hongrie la pologne
ainsi mis leur veto la semaine dernière
au budget pluriannuel et aux plans de
relance européens viktor orban année
matéos moravia qui indiqueront doublé
des sanctions à leur encontre à cause
des valeurs et qui ce qui est sur la
table sous le nom de primauté du droit
ce n'est pas la primauté du droit mais
plutôt la règle de la majorité
mais comme nous avons en débat sur de
nombreuses questions avec d'autres états
membres de l'ue en matière de migration
de souveraineté nationale ou encore de
moeurs
[Musique]
je ne peux pas faire courir à la hongrie
le risque d'être contrainte par une
majorité sur des questions que les
hongrois ne peuvent pas accepter
nous sommes face à un nouveau défi un
mécanisme totalement nouveau en raison
de son aspect arbitraire et de sa mise
en oeuvre politique
ce mécanisme est motivée par des
décisions politiques et peut même
conduire à la désintégration de lieux
ray pour en parler nous sommes avec
michel ruimy professeur à sciences po
spécialiste des marchés capitaux et de
l'économie monétaire bonsoir michel
ruimy merci d'être avec nous alors
hongrie et pologne 1 qui ont exprimé
leur condition et reste unie alors
peut-on lié état de droit et intérêts
financiers de l'union européenne
alors première des choses qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que le ce veto n'a pas
encore été exprimés au niveau du conseil
européen c'est-à-dire l'organe
décisionnel il a été exprimée au niveau
des du comité des représentants
permanents c'est à dire des ambassadeurs
des états membres donc on ne peut pas
parler aujourd'hui de veto officiel
alors ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
cette question de 2,2 de la pologne et
de la hongrie pause
je dirais plusieurs questions première
des choses
il convient à mon sens de devoir
qu'est-ce que quelles sont les valeurs
et européennes et quelles sont celles de
l'état de droit parce que tant qu'on n'a
pas défini ce que c'était ce qui est au
coeur de l'état de droit c'est à dire
les limites du pouvoir politique on
arrivera à aucune avancée deuxième chose
également sa pose aussi des questions de
mécanismes de prise de décision au
niveau de l'union européenne qui sont
toujours à l'unanimité des vingt-sept et
là l'idée ce serait de passer de
l'unanimité à la majorité donc c'est
vrai que cela pose des problèmes
malgré tout malgré tout dans cette
affaire ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
qu'il ya des possibilités de contourner
le veto
un première des choses c'est de
transférer le contenu du plan de relance
dans un accord international qui
pourrait être ratifiée par les 25 autres
états membres c'est ce qui s'était passé
avec la crise des dettes souveraines
avec la grèce lorsque l'on m'a t on est
passé par un traité international pour
établir un mécanisme européen de
stabilité de le pacte européen
mais sinon il ya aussi une autre
possibilité c'est passer par une
coopération renforcée c'est à dire une
procédure qui en fait qui ne s'applique
pas aux 27 membres mais qui s'applique
uniquement à ceux qui le désirent c'est
à dire que généralement cette
coopération renforcée parce c'est quand
on n'arrive pas à avoir une ligne une
unanimité
donc ce sont deux techniques qui serait
extrêmement facile à mettre en place
mais puisqu'il existe déjà un texte
négocié mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que ça pose un problème pourquoi parce
que le principe de le mécanisme de
conditionnalité comme il est déconnecté
du plan de relance pourrait s'appliquer
à la pologne et à la hongrie alors même
qu'ils pourraient ne pas bénéficier du
plan de relance
donc je pense que aujourd'hui on est à
des pains poker menteur mais presque
dans la mesure où il faudrait que
aujourd'hui toute la difficulté c'est
que chaque les deux parties puissent
arriver à intégrer l'autre partie sans
que ça soit une défaite c'est que chacun
a mis face est une avancée l'un vers
l'autre telle manière que l'on puisse
arriver dont notamment la première des
choses pour bruxelles serait peut-être
bien de mettre d'abandonner la procédure
dite de ce qu'on appelle la critique le
sait qu'ils sont notamment pour la
violation présumée de l'état de droit
donc je pense que s'il ya un effort de
la commission à ce moment là à ce moment
là la pologne et la hongrie pourrait
s'arranger on pourrait avoir une sortie
vers le haut on est bon on n'est pas un
premier désaccord
l'union européenne avec les pays donc
avec la hongrie et la pologne qui en
font partie aussi
qu'est ce qu'on doit en tirer comme
conclusion aujourd'hui le fait c'est que
aujourd'hui l'europe elle devait on va
dire montrer au niveau de hauts niveaux
de passer aux états unis par exemple une
autonomie stratégique et de défense face
à lécher une puissance commerciale
aujourd'hui l'europe et sommet d'une
certaine manière d'affirmer ses valeurs
démocratiques et de voir un peu ce qu'on
l'entend parce que c'étaient des mots il
faut avoir un contenu maintenant
d'autre part en même temps il sera à mon
sens difficile de se passer de la
pologne et de la hongrie parce que ce
sont des pays importants et ça pourrait
ouvrir une boîte de pandore dans la
mesure où tant qu'on appelle spécifier
ce que c'était qu'un état de droit et
des valeurs européennes
et bien tout pourra s'y mettre et c'est
toujours en état de crise en situation
de crise qu'on précise les mots et les
précisions donc je pense qu'il aura une
avancé encore plus en avant avec cette
crise pour préciser certains éléments
qui étaient encore très imprécis je
pense pas qu'on aille jusqu'à
l'éclatement de l'union européenne merci
à michel a remis d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage dans le
reste de l'actualité visite aujourd'hui
du chef de la diplomatie russe à minsk
entretien de sergueï lavrov avec son
homologue ainsi qu'alexandre loukachenko
le président biélorusse dont la
réélection en août dernier est toujours
contestée par l'opposition
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
cléroux du côté de minsk on se trouve
davantage dans la continuité plutôt que
dans une évolution de la position russe
après avoir rencontré alexandre
loukachenko dans la matinée le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères s'est
entretenu avec son homologue biélorusse
l'occasion pour moscou de réaffirmer son
soutien à minsk notamment en confirmant
les accords de sotchi signé lors de la
dernière rencontre
vladimir poutine et alexandre lukashenko
sergueï lavrov
ainsi pu de nouveau pointé du doigt les
tentatives d'influencé extérieure dans
les processus internes à la biélorussie
nous avons constaté de nombreux cas
d'ingérence flagrante tant de la part
des américains que de ceux qui marchent
dans leur sillage dans les affaires
intérieures des états souverains sont
des méthodes malsaines qu'on appelle
révolution de couleur continuent d'être
utilisés y compris la manipulation de
l'opinion publique la création et le
soutien des forces ouvertement anti
gouvernementales tout en favorisant leur
radicalisation
nous notons également à quel point ces
méthodes s'applique à la république de
biélorussie le ministre russe s'est
également ému de la répression des
récentes manifestations contre la loi de
sécurité globale en france
la répression qui d'après lui si elle
s'était passé en russie aurait eu
d'importantes conséquences pour les
autorités qui lie actuellement en france
une vague de contestation contre le
projet de loi sur l'interdiction de
photographier filmer ou identifier d'une
façon ou d'une autre les agents des
forces de l'ordre
si cela se produisait en russie ou en
république de biélorussie
je peux imaginer le bruit que cela
ferait les parisiens les français et les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme centre est au-dess us mais on ne
voit finalement aucune réaction de la
part des organisations internationales
on utilise des canons à eau et des
grenades assourdissantes lors des
manifestations contre ce projet de loi
les manifestants eux mêmes sont
également livrés à des actes
provocateurs contre la police en se
servant des pierres et des bâtons
un policier a été blessé
il ya eu des reportages à ce sujet ce
programme n'est ce pas de 16,4 à venir
le partage c'est donc un deux poids deux
mesures que sergey lavrov dénonce ici en
mettant au même niveau les
manifestations biélorusse qui demande le
départ de loukachenko d'un côté et celle
contre la loi de sécurité globale en
france de l'autre reste avec nous dans
quelques instants ce sera les dites aux
échos jacques sapir qui est en train de
répondre à cette question
l'europe est elle condamnée à décrocher
de la croissance mondiale et puis
direction les états-unis le président
sortant continue de contester la
victoire de joe biden du 3 novembre
dernier
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soit j 1
des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième au film en est ce qu'on
pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les jambes et ça a été vu en
allemagne quatre fois moins de voix
qu'en france ça a été vu en autriche 4
fois moins de morts en france a été vu
en corée du sud etc
ça ne profite pas de deuxième pour
finalement pour que dépister
systématiquement les choses vont
recommencer
il y aura une troisième vague au
printemps et un troisième confinement il
ce pays sera évidemment cloués au sol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que c'est une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
faut protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas tous nos
problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a sur
le reste du monde vivant donc il faut il
faut arrêter de laisser les chasseurs
faire leur bêtise et je suis poli
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose de digne gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose alors jean francky
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
21h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france alors
que l'europe et des états unis sont en
pleine deuxième vague de qu'ovide la
chine et ses voisins asiatiques
repartent de l'avant creusant un peu
plus encore l'écart avec les économies
occidentales
avec cette crise l'europe est elle
condamnée à décrocher de la croissance
mondiale pourquoi est il plus difficile
pour nous européens de nous en sortir
on voit cela tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques bonsoir c'est fini alors jacques
pendant que nous on lisait on est un
petit peu englué n'y a pas d'autre mot
dans leur confinement la chine elle
evans a déjà tourné la page de
l'épidémie et oui c'est fini
la crise sanitaire la base c'est du
passé ou presque est d'être séparé que
pour la chine a c'est vrai aussi pour
des pays comme taiwan 2 vietnam ou la
corée alors il faut comprendre que ces
pays ils ont réagi de manière
indifférente à l'amiante en régie les
pays européens et ce qui fait qu'il
semble épargner en particulier par cette
fameuse deuxième vague que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
le résultat c'est évidemment que leur
économie ont beaucoup moins souffert de
l'épidémie et surtout qu'elles
reprennent leurs activités beaucoup plus
vite que nous rien le traité qui a été
signé le 15 novembre dernier vous savez
ce fameux air ce pays où ce partenariat
économique régionale globale et d'un
indicateur aussi de comment les choses
sont en train d'évoluer
alors la question évidemment qu'on se
pose tous est ce que ces pays on
appliquer des mesures plus ou moins
sévères que nous face à la pandémie
alors une question intéressante c'est
fini cela dépend en fait on voit quand
on compare à un petit peu les mesures
qui ont été prises sur ces pays que
certains ut ont pris des mesures qui
étaient très faibles d'autres ont pris
des mesures qu'il est par contre
extrêmement sévère on voit par exemple
que à taiwan les mesures ont été légères
mais que en corée au vietnam en cours
lit encore plus en chine évidemment il
ya on est en présence de mesures qui ont
été extrêmement sévère
pourtant et là où il faut regarder un
petit peu sur l'axé vertical du
graphique
eh bien ces mesures ont beaucoup moins
détériorés l'activité économique que les
mesures qui ont été prises chez nous en
fait ce qui est en cause c'est le fait
que ces mesures ont souvent été très
différentes
ainsi les différents pays asiatiques ont
fermé leurs frontières
ce que la france en particulier s'est
refusé à faire pour des raisons qui sont
essentiellement idéologique
le résultat c'est que nous avons connu
un recul de notre activité qui est
beaucoup plus important
alors jacques comment cela se traduit-il
sur l'activité précisément stéphanie
selon que l'activité est plutôt
industriels ou plutôt dans les services
évidemment il ya des différences on l'a
vu par exemple dans le graphique
précédent avec le cas de la route et
dont l'économie est essentiellement
centré sur l'industrie mais si on prend
en compte uniquement justement cette
c'est cette question de l'industrie eh
bien on voit que là encore la chute de
la production en chine
elle a été plutôt plus faible que dans
les autres pays et que l la chine s'est
redressée beaucoup plus rapidement par
exemple quatre mois après le pic de la
crise la chine avait retrouvé son niveau
de décembre 2019 alors que en août c'est
à dire quatre mois après le pic d'avril
aucun des pays que ce soit les
etats-unis la russie ou la france manman
n'avait retrouvé plus de 95% de ce
fameux niveau
ainsi la france a été le pays le plus
affecté et la russie lui paient le moins
souffert d'une certaine manière mais on
voit très bien que quatre mois après la
crise ils sont approximativement au même
niveau mais pourquoi c'est forcément la
question qu'on a envie de vous poser
jacques alors il ya plusieurs raisons
d'abord il faut dire que en chine et
demi a surtout été concentrées dans la
province du hubei
là où se trouve la ville de one les
mesures de confinement qui ont été
prises localement on était très très
sévères elles l'ont été moins dans le
reste du pays et donc l'activité
économique a un petit peu moins souffert
après ce qui est frappant c'est que la
chine a quasiment interrompu ses
communications avec le reste du monde
le transport aérien encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il faut le souligner n'est
qu'à 5 ou 6 % de ce qu'il était avant
l'épidémie et on observe la même chose
avec le taïwanais taiwan la corée ou
avec le vietnam tous les pays ont fermé
leurs frontières ont mis en place des
règles de 14 n extrêmement stricte sur
les personnes qui souhaitaient y entrer
et d'ailleurs il en va de même pour la
russie alors quelles seront les
conséquences de cette situation
alors il est absolument évident c'est
fanny que non seulement les pays qui
sont autour de la chine arrêté nous a
affectés mais surtout qu'il semble se
relever et bien plus et nous on va le
voir d'ailleurs sur un graphique on voit
là que si on regarde les taux de
croissance tels qu'ils étaient estimés
avant la deuxième vague parce que ce
sont des calculs qui ont été faites et
qui ont été faits au mois de septembre
eh bien on voit que l'écart se creuse de
manière tout à fait spectaculaire entre
les pays développés comme la france
l'allemagne le japon et des etats-unis
d'un côté et la chine de l'aude
alors bien évidemment avec les
conséquences économiques du continent
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
eh bien on va voir cet écart se creuser
encore plus les pays qui ont su
préserver en partie leurs économies
comme l'allemagne ou les états unis
seront peut-être un petit peu moins
affecté que ceux qui ont plus ou moins
arrêter leurs activités mais ils
prendront eux aussi un retard important
sur la chine est globalement sur toutes
les aiguilles sud est ce enfin la cause
de 19 et bien elle a été révélatrice de
tendances ur qui sont présentes en
réalité depuis dix à vingt pas alors
concrètement c'est à dire bien
c'est à dire que ça fait des années en
réalité que les pays européens que la
zone euro accumulent du retard dans son
développement
la croissance moyenne de la zone euro a
été l'une des plus faibles du monde
depuis l'institution de l'euro et là on
le voit sur ce graphique aussi on voit
que nous allons être pour les prochaines
années en récession
plusieurs années alors que les pays
émergents dont les pays d'asie
évidemment il est en particulier eux
eh bien ils vont continuer à se
développer extrêmement rapidement même
la russie va faire mieux que la zone
euro dans ses prochaines années alors
essentiellement deux raisons à cela
il y a le fait que l'euro joue le rôle
d'un espèce d une fois à la croissance
mais il ya aussi le fait que nous sommes
en fait spectateurs autour de lui d'une
croissance qui tend à se développer
essentiellement dans la zone
asie-pacifique qui est en train de
devenir le pôle de croissance mondiale
seulement ce pôle va être sous contrôle
chinois
et c'est ici que prend tout son sens
l'accord de libre échange qui a été
signé à pékin le 15 novembre
le rcp et qui inclut 7 narre le point
intéressant y compris des pays qui ont
des relations politiques plutôt
difficile avec le film donc en clair
jacques ça veut dire que le kobe 2009
c'est un petit peu la fin de l'europe
telle que nous la connaissons
mais oui c'est un risque si on n'y fait
rien si on ne prend pas des mesures le
retard que nous sommes en train de
prendre et qu'il sera cumulatif or ce
retard va nous mettre dans une situation
difficile
le jour où nous aurons à négocier avec
la chine l'exemple du ralliement de
l'australie ou de la nouvelle zélande à
l'accord chinois doit nous servir de
leçon
si nous continuons sur ce chemin ce sera
la satellisation politique mais aussi la
satellisation économie seulement la
question qui se pose c'est pour nous
combler ce retard avec le carcan de
l'euro bien ça on peut malheureusement
au bouton merci jacques peut-être que
certains entendront votre avertissement
merci héros
michael flynn n'aura finalement pas de
peines d'emprisonnement hier donald
trump accordé une grâce à son ancien
conseiller à la sécurité nationale en
2017 michael flynn avait plaidé coupable
d'avoir menti au fbi au sujet de ses
contacts avec un diplomate russe
dans cette enquête sur l'ingérence russe
dans la présidentielle de 2016 il
risquait une peine maximale de six mois
de prison
mais le président sortant a décidé
autrement voyez
le président le tweet du président entre
eux j'ai le grand honneur d'annoncer que
le général michael flynn a obtenu une
grâce complète
félicitations à vous et à votre
merveilleuse famille je sais que vous
allez maintenant passer une saint xvi
ving vraiment fantastique est toujours
aux états unis donald trump qui
n'accepte pas la défaite et appelle
maintenant ses partisans à renverser et
l'élection
une sortie surprenante alors qu un à un
les états clés confirment la victoire de
joe biden et détails avec pierre et sa
vie hivernaux la pilule ne passe
définitivement pas pour donald trump le
président sortant battu lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle
américaine continue de contester le
résultat final sans preuve et malgré ses
revers en justice en pennsylvanie hier
il s'est adressé au sénateur républicain
via son avocat d'une façon pour le moins
originale j'apprécie d'avoir été invité
à prendre la parole et je suis dans le
bureau ovale en ce moment même c'est
très intéressant de voir ce qui se passe
c'est une élection que nous avons gagné
facilement
nous l'avons largement emporté un déni
qui continue donc plus de trois semaines
après le scrutin
à l'occasion de thanksgiving joe biden
depuis son fief de wilmington dans le
delaware a tenu à répondre aux propos de
donald trump notre démocratie a été mise
à l'épreuve cette année
et voilà ce que nous avons appris le
peuple de cette nation a été à la
hauteur en amérique nous avons des
élections libres et justes et nous en
respectant les résultats les habitants
et les lois de ce pays n'accepteront pas
autre chose
ces derniers jours à donald trump
semblait enclin à accepter sa défaite
lundi
il donnait son feu vert au processus de
transition qui permettent à joe biden de
constituer sa future équipe
aujourd'hui l'idée d'une passation de
pouvoir en douceur semble une nouvelle
fois compromise c'est la guerre des mots
et de l'image qui se poursuit en 3
donald trump et joe biden
le président sortant appelle ses
partisans à inverser le scrutin alors
que la victoire du démocrate à la
présidentielle a été officiellement
certifié mardi en pennsylvanie avec la
certification des comptes par le
gouverneur de cet état américain
ils se battent déclare le président élu
donald trump a t'il vraiment perdu at-il
épuisé tous ses recours c'est l'objet
d'un autre face à face ce soir et pour
en débattre nous sommes avec ericsson
semaine chargée de relations médias pour
les républicaine saut vers 6 friends
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous théo
lobry animateurs du groupe bernie
sanders france bonsoir à vous aussi
donald trump qui appelle donc ses
partisans à inverser le scrutin alors
qu'il a donné son feu vert pour la
transition c'est une nouvelle
provocation à l'égard de son rival
théologie oui bah disons que c'est un
petit peu à l'image de ce qui fait
depuis plusieurs mois voire même depuis
plusieurs années puisque déjà dès 2016
il avait dit qu'il ne reconnaîtrait pas
la victoire d'hillary clinton
j'ai envie de dire par là que c'est
simplement un fait de plus
alors certes c'est ses marques en ça
rentrera dans l'histoire puisque c'est
sûrement une des premières fois qu'on a
un déni pareil de la part d'un président
je rappelle qu'il y a quand même plus de
6 millions de voix d'écart entre joe
biden et donald trump alors certes c'est
un collège électoral mais on voit que
les scores termine à 306 grands
électeurs pour joe biden et 232 me
semble-t-il pour donald trump donc c'est
une victoire qui est assez large dans
les états on est à + dans les états
serré on a entre 10000 et 50 mille voix
d'écart donc nous ne sommes plus du tout
dans le cadre
de 2000 entre george bush et al gore où
ça s'était joué à une centaine de voix
en floride
donald trump je crois ne mettra pas sa
défaite puisque ce n'est pas dans son
caractère mais les institutions
américaines tiennent bon la démocratie
américaine a tenu bon et malgré tous les
mensonges alors qu'il s'en serve
dangereux pour la suite
puisqu'une bonne partie des américains
en particulier des électeurs
républicains croient donald trump sur
parole malgré le fait qu'il ait perdu et
que toutes les institutions reconnaisse
sa défaite
mais après tout bon bain l'essentiel
c'est simplement qu' une passation que
donald trump soit là ou pas pour la
faire après tout ce n'est qu'un détail
en tout cas officiellement annoncé un
perdant dans l'état de pennsylvanie on
l'a dit si ce qui n'a pas empêché de le
faire réagir écouter ça a été un scrutin
frauduleux et ne le pouvons pas laisser
cela se produire
nous ne pouvons pas laisser cela se
produire pour notre pays et cette
élection doit être inversée
parce que nous avons gagné la
pennsylvanie de beaucoup et nous avons
gagné tous ses états clés du livre de
donald trump votre champion n'arrive pas
à digérer sa victoire à l'ex peine que
cherchent-ils selon vous ben ils le
cherchent à en terminer avec le
l'historique bien connue des démocrates
de de tricher aux élections
présidentielles je vous rappelle qu'en
1960 c'était le président eisenhower
avait dit à nixon de contester
l'élection car il y avait eu des
tricheries temps dans la ville de
chicago que dans l'état du texas de
winneden baines johnson
depuis ce temps il ya toujours eu des
irrégularités
je dirais dire qu'il n'ya pas de dire
comme ça proclamer qu'il n'y a aucune
preuve
2 comment de fraude électorale à
philadelphie ce équivalent à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de preuves de fraudes
électorales à marseille ou à nice
chicago
l'équivalent vie et venez soir à séoul
aubry qu'est ce que vous répondez à eric
semaine quand vous dites voilà
c'est gonflé la part en gros des
démocrates ne pas reconnaître des
fraudes ou lui dit quoi
exc prod là elle représente absolument
rien c'est c'est toutes les études le
montrent et c'est ce que c'est ce que
c'est ce que je j'avais déjà dit la
dernière fois c'est que c'est moins de 0
01 % des voix qui sont frauduleuses
alors certes quand il y à des fraudes il
faut les punir
mais c'est toujours à la marge ça ne
change absolument rien d'ailleurs c'est
marrant de voir où mon contradicteur ce
soir républicain parler de tricherie
démocrate alors en rappelant qu'elle est
dit alors c'était c'était effectivement
une autre époque et puis nixon avait
aussi très certainement mis la main dans
le pot de confiture comme on dit mais il
faut se rappeler qu'en 2000
c'est bien le scandale il est notre bien
avec bush qui gagne la floride
son frère jeff boucher gouverneur de
floride
la cour suprême tranche plus ou moins en
faveur de georges w bush et al gore
sachant que l'amérique va cirer si
jamais ils allaient un petit peu plus
loin dans la contestation du résultat a
préféré céder céder la victoire à son
adversaire
bon ça entraîner derrière l'invasion de
l'irak et toutes les les problématiques
militaire au moyen-orient peut-être qu
al gore à cette époque là on aurait dû
aller un peu plus loin mais en attendant
aujourd'hui l'écart est tel qu'il n'y a
aucune contestation possible vis-à-vis
du vainqueur c'est dubaï donne point
c'est tout maintenant j'y vais
régulièrement des preuves vidéo leur
byden et paris c'est un petit peu
compliqué de laisser la parole aux
autres m si les républicains amène des
uniquement des preuves vidéo qu'ils ont
retrouvé sur youtube ou sur des comptes
twitter qua none jusque on sait qu' il
ya une filiation entre le président
américain et mouvements
conspirationnistes qua none
bon ben si ça ça sert de preuve et que
c'est suffisant dans ce cas là pourquoi
pas la justice tranche jour après jour
contre donald trump tourné à 35,35
procès entre guillemets perdu par
l'équipe présidentielle
rudy giuliani qui à l'époque était
considéré comme le maire de l'amérique
aujourd'hui se révèle être un avocat
médiocre x men comme vous l'a glissé un
débat donc chacun se laisse parler et
l'ex peine la réponse à notre bon on est
complètement bafouée par barça a eu
l'idée était que d'entendre d'entendre
ça sur le fac et cela fait quatre ans
que les démocrates répète à tue-tête qui
a eu des tricheries pendant l'élection
de 2016 monsieur contient nous dit aussi
qu'il des tricheries en 2000 c'est à
chaque fois qu'ils aient les
républicains ccd tricherie c'est la
phrase et moi messieurs on va pas se
mettre d'accord pardonnez-moi tourner en
rond parce que personne n'a rien vu
encore se mettre d'accord sur le fait de
qui a triché n'est pas ce soir qu'on va
convainc élucider cette question mais
j'aimerais vous poser une question quand
même avec ses 6 millions de voix d'écart
est ce que ce n'est pas plutôt le le
coude après qu'un cherche à faire donald
trump finalement aujourd'hui on dit que
le tropisme c'est désormais un courant
politique c'est pas cinq cherche la
stratégie c'est pas ça la stratégie
justement de votre poulain ben je suis
on est étonné que rome était en train de
gagner toute l'élection toute la nuit
soudain au milieu de la nuit
philadelphie est et trois autres villes
serre mais le comptage des voix
c'est inouï sait nager movsissian ni en
amérique ni dans un an ni en france ni
dans aucun autre pays
et quand ils reprennent le matin parce
qu'ils personne bien sûr aucun démocrate
m'était resté là dans les bureaux
pendant la nuit
soudain voilà que joe biden est devant
et nous sommes censés croire cela
rappelle je vois mails pendant quatre
ans on ne les gens s'étaient pas cannon
c'était les démocrates à il a fait il
il a travaillé avec le russe à ses
bottines qui l'a fait gagner et mouloud
la seule chose qu'on dise ce qu'elle est
c'est que les villes démocrates ont
triché et il comment ils en font des
fonds comme le font depuis longtemps
d'une belle lurette et la marâtre
chicago et philadelphie n'ont pas eu de
maires républicains depuis 70 ans
et là le meilleur le meilleur exemple
c'est la nouvelle orléans la paye de mer
est plus qu'un depuis 1876 mais non non
non c'est jamie et jamais de tricherie
alors le truc à joe biden lui veut
tourner la page america is back nous dit
joe biden c'est son slogan pour cette
toute nouvelle étape je compose
d'écouter son message je sais pas mais
nous devons nous rappeler que nous
sommes en guerre contre le virus
pas les uns contre les autres on
trouvera les uns avec les autres
ouais la lutte contre la crise sanitaire
la priorité aux états unis désormais
alors que joe biden n'est pas encore
installée à la maison blanche est ce
qu'il ne grille pas trop vite les étapes
théo lobry je ne pense pas c'est le
problème numéro un aux états unis comme
comme ailleurs dans le monde cette crise
sanitaire
et il a bien raison effectivement
d'anticiper notamment il a encore plus
raison d'anticiper puisque donald trump
lui met des bâtons dans les roues
c'est tout à fait normal c'est le
président élu il prendra ses fonctions
dans environ deux mois
c'est normal qu'il anticipe cette sortie
aussi importante de joe biden les états
unis qui sont de nouveau prêts à guider
le monde
théo lobry tout de même que doit-on
comprendre avec cette sortie un petit
peu surprenante guider le monde
eh ben c'est quand joe biden parle d'
america is back
c'est en opposition bien entendu america
first de donald trump c'est un retour
dans les instances
multilatéralisme comme l'onu l'om est-ce
l'unesco c'est avant tout ce genre de
chose à quoi il faut s'attendre dès
demain c'est à dire que quand on est
guide on est devant et on montre
l'exemple aux autres normalement c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'ont fait les états
vis que la seconde guerre mondiale
depuis quelques années alors c'est pas
propre à donald trump
mais les etats-unis se désengage du
multilatéralisme et si joe biden peut
recourir au renvoi du multilatéralisme
et aux instances internationales pour
essayer de de guider le monde alors
c'est une formule très américaine je
suis pas sûr qu'en france on est
forcément envie d'être guidé comme des
enfants mais en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec le
désengagement des états unis et
l'arrivée de la chine le monde et risque
d'être guidés par les chinois dans les
décennies à venir et je ne sois je ne
suis pas certain que ce soit être très
très bonne chose entre excellent
effectivement est ce que les états unis
ont encore les moyens de guider le monde
et ça sera la dernière question bon et
bien sûr ils ont ils ont les moyens de
guider le monde
déjà dans la halle trump avait guidé le
monde 2 pour partir de la chine qui ont
à toutes les économies
tous les pays occidentaux ont ouvert
leurs économies leurs secrets leurs
secrets militaires chinois et c'est bien
sur ce que va refaire jobs haydn avec
son fils fincher by dvd qui définit des
millions de la part des chinois ou delà
de la femme de l'âme dit merde de moscou
et c'est bien sûr ça va ça va reprendre
le comme ça et nous on avait une vision
d'un numérique qui se laissait pas ce
père qui vont des patous labaye ce que
j'ai aimé chaise mon contradicteur ce
dès qu'ils disent
il va mettre des bâtons dans les roues
de dubaï les démocrates ne font rien
d'autre que de mettre des bâtons dans
les roues des jobs de danse depuis
quatre ans et mais là c'est sensé les
trois héroïque penser un républicain qui
le fait voilà qu ancien républicain
qui gagne c'est le populaire c'est le
populisme qui gagne france est un
gauchiste qui gagne c'est la démocratie
qui gagne c'est la même chose qu'en
france on vous mettra pas d'accord en
tout cas messieurs eric aspen et théo
lobry merci d'avoir accepté ce débat en
direct sur rt france merci à vous deux
l'hommage à diego maradona en argentine
et la veillée funèbre qui a débuté au
palais présidentiel de buenos aires des
dizaines de milliers de fans défilent
devant la dépouille du leader du
football décédé mercredi à 60 ans des
suites d'une crise cardiaque et des
incidents survenus à l'intérieur du
palais ont forcé les autorités à retirer
le cercueil installée dans une chapelle
ardente tandis que des affrontements ont
éclaté avec la police dans les rues
alentour le président argentin fernandez
a décrété trois jours de deuil national
et parmi les moments forts de sa
carrière diego maradona a été champion
du monde avec l'équipe argentine c'est
lors de son match face à l'angleterre au
mexique en 1986 pendant cette
compétition qu'il a construit sa légende
et marqué l'un des plus beaux buts de
toute l'histoire du foot il était aussi
connu pour ses engagements politiques
retour sur une vie exceptionnelle avec à
des lacrymo ranimer grégoire dos et le
che du sport
voilà comment était surnommé diego
maradona par fidel castro lui-même
ancien compagnon de route du
révolutionnaire argentin
au delà de son statut de joueur de
légende l'ancien génial numéro 10 était
également connu pour sa dimension
politique et ses choix symbolique et ce
alors qu'il était à l'apogée de sa
carrière professionnelle en 1984 il
quitte le prestigieux fc barcelone pour
rejoindre la modeste équipe de naples
l'enfant des bidonvilles de la banlieue
de buenos aires emmène le club sur le
toit de l'italie et de l'europe
après la fin de sa carrière el pibe de
oro concrétise ses engagements par le
biais de plusieurs déclarations et
rencontres fortes en 2016 il rend un
hommage appuyé à fidel castro dont il
était très proche
comme un clin d'oeil du destin le lider
maximo des scènes également un 25
novembre
c'est une journée horrible on m'a
annoncé la mort de celui qui a été le
plus grand sans aucun doute
fidel castro est mort je suis
terriblement triste parce qu'il était
pour moi comme un second père maradona a
toujours assumé son adhésion aux idées
du socialisme latino américains après
son soutien inconditionnel à hugo chavez
il n'hésite pas à prendre la défense de
son successeur nicholas maduro tout en
égratignant au passage le président
américain donald trump
je veux dédier cette victoire à nicholas
maduro et à tout le venezuela qui
souffre actuellement à cause des shérifs
du monde que sont les yankees qui
pensent pouvoir nous mener ce tyran
qu'ils ont comme président ne nous
achètera pas l'une des dernières prises
de positions fortes de diego maradona
concerne le conflit israélo palestinien
après avoir fustigé à plusieurs reprises
le comportement de l'état hébreu il
rencontre mahmoud abbas en 2018
à l'occasion de la coupe du monde en
russie depuis l'annnonce de la mort de
celui qui est considéré comme un demi
dieu dans son pays
les hommages se multiplient dans le
monde entier preuve de son statut
exceptionnel
l'argentine a décrété trois jours de
deuil national
leo messi souvent présenté comme le
successeur de diego maradona a salué sa
mémoire par ces mots il nous quitte mais
ne disparaît pas parce que diego est
éternel
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes à 22
heures pour un point complet sur
l'actuelle
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]